do you know you know my story of Mitzi
right no well I never became a regular
the conversation why my name's not on
the wall why oh so I get to La like
everybody else and I did the the song
and dance for you wait in line on
whatever day that was for three hours
Sundays yeah to try to become a paid
paid regular did that a couple of weeks
but can I just say this the system back
then was [__] you haven't let me
finish okay
it wasn't the wait in line part so they
after a couple weeks
so no so I get picked they call me they
go hey this whatever Monday there was
five of us going up to try to become pay
regulars and it was four girls and me
and I was fifth so I'm sitting there and
you know I'm ready and I know I'm ready
yeah I go up there and I and I'm not
trying to be conceited but I had the
best set of the five of us obviously
when I looked in the back when I got up
after the four girls mitzi's back there
and she's got the four girls around her
talking just holding court with them and
I'm going she's not watching me she's
not watching me so then when I called
the next day like what happened my pay
breaker they go no no Mitzi said you're
not ready and I go hmm and I said I'll
never
go up
like that again and then I started doing
Fat Tuesday and I was it was kind of
like my middle finger like I don't
really need to be at the you know that's
what I'm talking about is the system
it's like
because same thing happened with Lucy K
that's right I was sitting next to Mitzi
when Louis CK was
auditioning and she used to do three
minutes
45 seconds to admit it in
she just goes light them
shut up yeah and I turned to her and
this is and Louis had already done an
HBO special that's crazy Christ it
wasn't like you know I mean he was a new
guy he's like a legend already right
what year is this I don't know I mean
back when 90s right yeah and I I turned
to her and I go no no missy you
got shout out uh what you call um she
always thought it was Peter chin
[Laughter]
another Asian guy named Peter yeah yeah
I remember Peter yeah you remember Peter
yeah
Peter Chell was the guy is when I first
came to the LA he came up to me because
the only one Asia around here I'm the
guy is that him
Peter Chen would have his own Heckle
lines
you know you know you know those hacky
heck of lines like you know I mean you
know I mean you know don't [__] with me
while I'm working I don't go to the
[__] whatever whatever yeah yeah
whatever I don't go to McDonald's and
knock the fries or the fryer yeah yeah
yeah that's a hacky line but Peter Chen
goes I I come up with my own um rebutter
like so one night we saw him and he goes
some guy was hackling me goes hey don't
talk to me what I don't stand up or I'll
put you on a rocket ship you go right
straight to the Moon that's the guy
right we're all back there going
doesn't make any sense you know what I
mean but he would like make up his own
Heckle line yeah I mean so anyway
um but that's why I never was a regular
yeah you know that yeah I think that if
you were to do the process now because
it took you know a mirror k
he's
um you know he he is my boy and for the
longest time no I don't know him yeah
he's so funny but for like six years
constantly I was just like this is the
guy this guy and he finally got through
now he's getting spots it takes a while
and I don't know why it takes so so much
but Amir is so [__] funny and you
remind me of Amir reminds me of you I
mean because you guys are just both guys
are just so obviously to me
just obviously funny they should be
playing everywhere but that what you
described about like going up there and
someone just like completely checked out
and not listening and doing other things
it's the worst it's the worst feeling
because they're going she's not you're
you're doing your set and you're
watching her talk to people and I go
she's not watching me yeah she's not
watching but it was those girls
sabotaging you
yeah probably but also it seemed like a
Mitzi problem yeah come here I want to
talk to you like it was like she was
here and they were around her and I was
like oh she's not watching me at all
heartbreaking and then I thought okay
maybe she's you know in your brain the
conceited part goes I'll try to need to
watch me yeah like she already knows
what it is yeah I walked on my left foot
them girls are doing right
[Music]
when you would showcase was there a
crowd or was it average I mean you're
not in the the big room in the original
original room yeah and it was the normal
weekday probably half full you know
they're there those original rooms back
in the day it was weird because I'd sit
in the back and watch people but it'd be
like
the energy below
but then once if you would get them you
get them it's a hard room though yeah
I've had some disasters in that room
I've seen them yeah
I sat in the back it was just you I've
seen Knights yeah yeah I've seen like
five comics in a row disaster oh my God
so and then the guy would go up with the
balloons yeah Top Gun [__] every night
oh yeah yeah Don baras yeah
or not the music's so loud you can't
hear it anyway yeah it was it was a Top
Gun song yeah
yeah
I remember that yeah yeah and then there
was a guy named Robert aprivaya
so there's this man who was homeless not
even Robert he was homeless he wore a
green suit right and he would talk to
himself
he would talk to himself and Mitzi for
the last since probably the eight early
eighties just let him close the open mic
I I almost was like this so he he was a
pay rigger yeah he got passed huh did he
really no he did yes no no no
you know it's so funny because
Steve Harvey once I saw him walk into
the uh Comedy Store and he spit on the
wall [__] this place
um you know it's like I and I I you know
Seinfeld had the same thing they're just
certain people George Lopez as well
because George Lopez yelled at her same
thing happened she was I never yelled at
her I know he did though he snapped
during his show because he goes hey
[__] I came all the way down here
you're not even listening that sounds
like George yeah hey [__] yeah yeah so
my point is is that you're not the only
guy I've seen so many guys go through
that process and just not even get
anything and it's like I don't
understand how that happens but it's
also you have to understand that you're
so sensitive around her because at any
any given moment she could just inner
mind decide I don't like him yeah yeah
yeah you know I mean so you have to kind
of be in tiptoes around her you know did
you find Robert William rapper via
is that him yep I don't remember him he
looks incredible
I mean I would cast him in a Wes
Anderson movie immediately I know but he
would show up
out of nowhere younger thin air yeah oh
my God yeah and he's cool looking dude
he's a scary looking dude to me you